thank you for the invitation to come
here and speak and welcome everyone so
how many of you have taken a course that
teaches you hybrid systems okay more
people coming how many of you have taken
a course that teaches you model
predictor control and I guess my next
answer was if you took a course with
hybrid systems and model predator
control but maybe the answer is clear so
today I'm gonna be talking about those
two things and so I wanted to start with
what are hybrid systems and I wanted to
show you some of the applications of
hybrid system this is hybrid because
this manipulators which could be robots
and maybe it's hard to see where there
are little dots that make contact with
these object as they move along and as
they move along we would like the
contact to clear at the same time so
that this object doesn't get disturb
because it could be a ball and it could
be rolling if you impact with one end
effector at a time so this is
essentially a system where in between
the contacts you have continuous motion
and as soon as the contact occurs some
quantity will change very rapidly
imagine the velocity of this and the
factors changing very rapidly
that would be what we would call an
impulse into the system we will model it
very abruptly like a jump on the
variable and it will become clear as we
go along this is a very classical hybrid
system you see it here this is the ball
bouncing on the ground don't get
distracted by the airplane on the back
but this is a ball that every time that
there is an impact there is a very rapid
change of the velocity of the ball he
goes from going down to going up and
what we want to do is create a periodic
pattern is a juggling pattern okay so
you can model and we're going to do this
today you can model the behavior of the
bonding between the impacts with a
differential equation basic physics I
mean every time there is an impact you
can say the velocity changes very
rapidly
I'm not going to model the compression
of the ball the impact with the piston
I'm gonna say that the velocity changes
abruptly and they will be what is called
a Newton's restitution law so many of
you should have heard before
secrets is one of those were hybridity
pops up very rapidly here we have a
switch in the middle anyone knows what
this is about this is in any of your
devices you use it all the time even
though you don't know it this is a
converter this converts DC voltage to a
larger DC like voltage this is a boost
converter it amplifies voltage by
switching this switch very surreal so we
turn there is a switch with something
changing changing very rapidly and this
is a planar trajectory of the current
and the voltage on this circuit and a
controller that essentially is taking
these quantities to a set point which is
the little point in the middle by
switching okay so every time that the
trajectory hits one of these boundaries
what we get is a switch of the switch
position okay and as you see you can
trap it nearby where we want to go so
that's another example of hybrid most
likely from the controller strategy
which again sets the switching surfaces
were the decisions in the controller
will change the position of a switch
okay so the closed-loop system of this
feedback system that is hybrid is
naturally having body was a chain
continuously and variables and change
discretely in this case I will put a
logic variable that says the switches on
or the switches off and those values
will essentially be my hybrid values on
my system state another electric circuit
this one you probably know what is this
there's an h-bridge is a single phase
inverter essentially you put DC voltage
here you get something you want to have
which is AC voltage okay so you convert
by switching on and off you put this on
these off and then the other way around
you create a square signal at the square
signal then it gets filtered by this
low-pass filter right here and then you
feed the load with a pseudo sinusoidal
signal typically you use pulse width
modulation to switch the transistors
that you see right there to select on
and off and you can use also other
techniques so hybrid techniques is one
of them as I said you want to create a
periodic motion on your circuit
essentially a sinusoidal voltage output
and one way to do that is to say well my
blue trajectory is by the side
trajectory and all I can do is to switch
these transistors okay I cannot create
that perfectly that's the nature of a
problem so how do you do that well one
way to do that is to put these switching
surfaces again and I will pick the
configuration of my switches according
to which configuration will keep the
trajectory the voltage and the current
within this band okay so you can
approximate as you go forward in time
the blue trajectory with arbitrary
precision by switching and keeping it
within that green band okay so the more
accuracy you want the smaller the band
the more switching you will have that's
the price to pay and then you can
guarantee that you get this periodic
motion to create your output voltage you
might wonder well what if the secret is
start somewhere here I initialize
everything at zero well you could have
another controller that brings the
current and the voltage to this band and
then once you seen that when you switch
to a controller that keeps it in the
band okay you see that so that's a deal
hybridity that's what higher control
shows up and it helps you many problems
to actually achieve the solution in
smaller pieces building blocks
separating the big problem into smaller
problems I will guarantee this property
which is actually called forward
invariance of Hizb and I started there a
stay there
with some dynamics of course it's not
just staying there because otherwise he
won't be very Alek and then I would like
to have anywhere I start in the state of
space my current and voltage to convert
to that and once you're there you keep
iterating this is actually one of our
patterns on fabric control for power
conversion so that's essentially
visually what hybrid systems are I'll
tell you the mathematics behind it but
if you walk away right now you will know
that hybrid systems combine variables
are changing continuously maybe
differential equation Murphy a partial
differential equation maybe some other
object at this point doesn't really
matter and you have variables that
change discretely after certain events
occur okay because variables could be in
the system itself like the piston and
the ball the ball please position and
velocity essentially the velocity
changes very abruptly what they can be
in the controller like in the switching
power conversion controller that I
mention to you and that's what we are
done the next thing I want to kind of
communicate in this lecture is what is
powder predictor control so the idea is
very simple yet very powerful yet very
challenging to achieve in many nonlinear
settings but let me just introduce it
basic what you do is to predict the
behavior of the system forward in time
that's intuition and then based on the
predictions that you would have in the
future for which we need to have a model
you will pick prior your best choice
okay I actually teach our UC Santa Cruz
the introduction course to robotics
freshmen they are really learning about
their careers it's much easier for me to
explain this technique than to explain
proportional control or PID which when
you really know about so it is very
simple so you look at your state in the
future this is X could be an
n-dimensional vector t ordinary time and
then you look at in the future and say
well everything went well up to here I'm
going to just apply the control input
that generate that motion up to some
time okay and after that time I will
rech imputed and that's what will happen
in the future
and then we were going to just do a
little bit of that and then I will do
that again over and over okay you most
likely do these periodically and most
likely do in maybe courses you took in
discrete time okay you discretize the
system and you do this for winter so the
good news is that if you do this as you
predict and as you make your choice you
can solve an optimization problem with
constraints you can attach a cost you
can probably maximize from where this
system will converge to the sire
configuration okay
typically in a linear control systems
typically the origin you want to
converge to the origin the zero point
order reference okay
inhabited this changes a little bit I'll
tell you more about this soon and and
one of the things that I kind of like
but also is kind of coming from more
water break to control that you don't
really need that closed form expression
for the controller right for
proportional control it's just like
constant again matrix right for PID in a
scalar case is the constant plus another
constant divided by s plus another
constant times s in the Laplace domain
so you have a closed form expression for
MPC Etan which is a block an optimizer
that gives the actual control impulse to
you okay so that's nothing to keep in
mind when do you when you do analysis
having a closed form expression is very
nice but when you don't have it in to
find another way so notice this picture
what we will like to attain today is the
hybrid version of this which is now I
have trajectories as I mentioned earlier
that change continuously but at certain
times have jumps okay think about the
velocity of the ball this jump that you
see right here the second jump could be
the velocity going down negative the
ball going down and then all of a sudden
the ball going up okay change your
negative to positive so that's what
we're going to try to do and if you
think about hybrid in the context of MPC
there are many articles very powerful
results in the literature where you can
see the use of the word hybrid the word
hybrid has not been used most times
to identify continuous behavior and
discrete behavior as in the examples I
show you it has been used to identify
the fact that you might have states that
have sub components that are continuous
states and some components that are
logical states or binary states okay
but in principle most times and I were a
survey about this you will find discrete
time models will mix logic state values
another situations where hybrid shows up
is when the dynamics of your system is
given by a function that is
discontinuous okay so if you're familiar
with nonlinear systems and I've
mentioned in a minute you're familiar
with X dot equal f of X if that has that
function typically called called the
right hand side is discontinuous you may
think that this is some sort of hability
okay or impulsivity that's another way
that you can think about hair Olympics
in the literature
another more closely related to what I'm
going to talk about today is situations
where hybridity is attached to the fact
that is switching in the system okay if
they're familiar with switch systems and
in the context of my previous example X
dot equal f of X now for a switch system
you have X dot equal F sub I all that of
X where I could be one two and three and
four okay so every time I pick a number
I I pick a different right-hand side or
vector field for my system and that
could be considered also hybrid so I
will continue with the discussion but
there are again in my opinion very
important results where the word
hybridity
is attached and you can look at the
references in the context of this talk I
will talk about a particular class of
hybrid systems which in my opinion is
very useful for for many of the
applications that I show you in some
other applications I will show you at
the end
so what we have done over the past year
or so and actually certain in the CDC
conference in France nice
in about a month we're gonna have a
pre-conference workshop on hybrid MPC a
full day today before the conference on
Tuesday talking about all the details
that are behind what we did one of the
things that we really have to do
understand is what is called records
feasibility in other words every time
that you can find a solution to your
system that source of the musician's
problem can you land at a point where
you can solve the problem again okay
that's a very important building block
of MPC once you do that and you write
down what is called the cost functional
for the MPC problem which I will mention
it in a minute
one thing that you like to do is to
guarantee that the origin as I mentioned
earlier or the reference that you want
to track or in general asset this has
said that the trajectories of your
system converts to and if you start
close to that set the trajectory say
stay close to that set okay that's two
properties each activity or convergence
and the other property stability and
that leads to what is called asymptotic
stability okay so that's the key thing
to improve and again without a closed
form expression for your model and with
jumps and without knowing when the jump
secured because if I know where the
jumps occurred in my system what's the
deal but I don't know where the ball
initialize I know know when the impact
will occur in general right well know
when the switch in this circuit will
bull occur because I have a very small
band and it's gonna be very hard to
calculate all the switching times there
will be millions of switches so I don't
want to know that and then there is
something else that is important to
handle which is what is called see no
behavior has anyone heard of see no
behavior in hybrid systems a couple of
you okay so so now in practice what this
means is that if
have xeno behavior you have very very
fast switches or very very fast jumps in
your system okay so putting in the
context of the converter problem you
don't want that to happen because if you
have a very very fast switching that
goes to zero the timing between switches
goes to zero then you're going to ask
too much from that secretary right it's
going to break so see no behavior is
important to detect but in some cases is
actually useful for an algorithm to
create senior mathematically because
then it converges very fast so you won't
allow that in in your system and you
don't want to rule it out so we were
able to allow that but most applications
that doesn't happen and then we can
discretize things so if I have time I'll
tell you some of the details we have
some software just now starting to
actually solve this optimization problem
with constraints with hydrodynamics and
those are very important but again we
don't discretize with on partition and
the idea is that we will have an MPC
scheme that will apply to the systems
that will pop up in those applications
okay and I've been in aerospace a
mechanical engine in the past and I know
that systems with impacts is one of
those for hybridity shows up we do need
or aspire space aerospace applications
we have an autopilot auto pilot have
multiple modes of operation right
landing cruise emergency those are all
hybrid type algorithms now so these are
just everywhere solutions like for
instance we have in the context of know
necessarily MPC we have an algorithm for
parameter estimation that converges in C
no time right so in a finite amount of
time you have infinitely many operations
and you have convergence that's not
practical but analytically you say well
after this time I will converge if I now
relax the switch in time a little bit I
will converge to a neighborhood of the
parameter of the true parameter if I
truncate essentially the rate of
switching so when you have that kind of
result and that continually type of
argument scene is not too bad okay we'll
get back to that but let me just give
you a little bit of examples of of some
of the hybrid models in MPC which are
not hybrid in the context of this course
but over the lecture but let me just say
that discrete-time systems boot
constraints these are piecewise affine
systems and now this a to the J and B to
the J so those matrices change according
to where you are in the state of space
okay so these are no nice moves you can
have essentially polytopes with
different constraints on different
dynamics mix logic dynamical systems is
another one where it's a pretty powerful
tool we're now actually playing with
this auxilary States Delta and see you
can craft very nice constraints and very
useful constraints for your problems and
they're all differential hydro Tomatoes
and so on so this is kind of my outline
for today I think I'll succeed with
everything that I wanted to to
communicate but the first step now to
figure out how do we model this hybrid
systems right beef again this is model
base and before I get into the litre so
hybrid MPC I need to tell you how do we
model this and let me just say there are
many ways to model hybrid systems if
you're familiar with high resistance
literature there are these ten
frameworks tomorrow hybrid systems this
is one of them it captures many of the
frameworks that are in the literature
some of them better than the other ones
is not the best is not the worst is one
that is very natural for people that are
familiar with control systems to
understand hybrid systems and it's
actually very powerful to understand
stability and robustness of hybrid
systems so let me tell you a little bit
more about that so now into the details
of hybrid systems so if I were to tell
you I have a continuous-time system I
pick an initial condition you will
expect hopefully that the evolution of
the system will be given by a trajectory
of this form we're going to call that
the solution
trajectory solution will be equivalent
to us okay so you start there and you
can a smoothly without lifting your pen
draw the trajectory forward in time
okay so let's continuous-time behavior
we might have at times discrete changes
so if my state is right here
it may be that the next time is here and
then the next time is here okay so now I
need to lift the pen my four-year-old
son understands this this is a really
good way to explain hybrid systems
before you know it's kind of dangerous
but then you can think about how
continues on the speed look like right
now I can put the things together and I
get this combination of continuous time
and discrete it might be after some time
I have one jump and then flow jump slow
or they might have multiple jumps at the
same time my controller keeps computing
okay in between the system evolving so
that's how a solution to a hybrid system
should look like in our context okay
the question now is when do I allow flow
blue and when do I allow jumps okay
that's a matter of semantics so one way
we do that which in my opinion is very
useful way is to define a set call it C
where blue flow is allowed okay so all
this blue tragical should be embedded or
contain him in the blue in in the in the
C set and then whenever it is a jump an
event that event will be essentially had
to be in a point in a set that I'm gonna
call D okay so I have multiple
possibilities here i canister my system
here and now all I can do is to jump
because I'm far from flow I can start
here or I can do this flow but not jump
but I can start in the bit in between on
this very old hat seek overlap and I can
choose what to do okay I'll tell you a
bit about why we need an overlap in a
minute I'm now going to attach
generators of these motions essentially
flow this is a continuous time
trajectory I will say is the solution to
a differential
equation X dot equal f of X maybe with
an input you okay so you give me an
input function of T give me an initial
condition X 0 I can find hopefully a
solution that satisfies the differential
equation okay if f is linear you know
how to do that Exponential's pop up if
it is nonlinear
good luck but you can simulate that's
one every time the degrees are reset or
a jump in my system the new value of a
state I'm going to say is given by
another function I'm going to call it a
jump map G and that at the current value
of a state under the current value input
tells me what the new value of the state
will be so this value is X and you write
here evaluating G alright so I can put
this together and now look what I have I
have a hybrid system I have a flow map F
and a flow set C if you're familiar with
continuous-time systems takes it to be
the entire space for state and input
forget about the take it empty and now
the second thing is time system with an
input every time there is a jump is
because I have a state on the input in
the jump set whenever that happens and
if there is a jump the new value of the
state which I denote X plus is given by
the jam map evaluated at X and you if
you're familiar with discrete-time
systems take C empty the entire space
for state and input and then you're back
to the script I'm comfy so but now I
have the two things at the same time
okay therefore I need to make sure that
I don't prioritize one over the other
so what I'm going to use is what we call
hybrid time and this is in different
works in the literature but whenever the
system flows T increases linearly T dot
equal to one and every time that there
is a jump J increase linearly j j plus
one okay
it's incremented it's a counter alright
so we have two times or a pair elements
the find harriet time t ordinary time j
jump time
with that we can say I will have a
solution of my system I'm at times and
only at times and maybe that's my
mathematician side but it's actually
always we might need to have a
differential inclusion in other words
this X dot my belonged was said rather
than to a function and this X plus the
new value of the state after the event
may belong to a set and this will be a
set G most of the talk will be with
single value case because of the problem
of non uniqueness that pops up right
here but let me just say that you can
characterize that Y to characterize
robustness because you can go from
equality to inclusion if you have
perturbations on your F and in your G
when a single idea well now that I told
you that you can think of now an initial
condition of my system let's say my
circuit and now there is no switch or
jump up to time T 1 so the system
variables flow again this is trivialized
for a scalar case but is n-dimensional
and every time that there is one of the
jump the state gets reset according to
my channel map and I increment my j from
0 to 1 and then from that I continue
onwards so I build these intervals of
flow if t1 is larger than 0 index by
number of jumps and I build what we call
our domain of time which is a hybrid
time domain because I have dnj you're
familiar with K perhaps for discrete
time systems so J is not K because K is
typically related to T as K times the
sampling time right so don't get
confused even though you can capture
discrete time systems this way an
example is in order to just put all
these things into a concrete case and
this is one of in my opinion the
canonical hybrid control problems where
you have a control product to stabilize
a plant to let's say to the origin and
now your sample themself and we obtain
your input the resolve and and here
there is an algorithm so this is what is
called sample that
control or sample and hold control
consider the plant you wanna control a
linear plant most of you have taken a
linear systems course I imagine you have
the plant state Z Z dot equal to a times
Z plus bu that's my plan okay now you is
only updated every time that there is a
sample event okay so I'm going to treat
you as a state component of my vector X
and every tender the recent event I'm
going to update my you to dagger ism law
which I assumed to be a linear
proportional controller so I mentioned
the current state that multiplied by K
that's my input I applied to the plant
when do the events occur well let's
assume periodic sampling I add a timer
tau s tau is not equal to in this case
decreasing minus 1
whenever the timer get gets to zero this
is an event I update my input I don't
change my plant state and my timer gets
reset to this value T s and from that
years decreases back to zero ok so you
see the flow set here which is a timely
inserted yes the jump set here tau is
equal to 0 the flow map right here there
is this nice linear map and this jump
map which is another nice linear affine
map ok so that's why I release it in
shows hydrodynamics what do you want a
star valid for the system Z you might
want to send it to 0 tau is you don't
really care 0 to t s and you because Z
goes to 0 you should go to 0 so you here
you wanna stabilize this set not the
origin which is 0 cross 0 to tears cross
serum make sense and I'm modeling
everything that goes in the hood for a
very simple case but a model in
everything that goes into the sample
hold control ok and I'm not discrediting
the plant even though I could but by you
know discretize of the plan I can
capture the inter sample behavior okay
all right so this is how trajectories
will look as expected timer let's say it
starts at zero jumps decreases input
gets updated every TS estate nicely goes
to zero okay so now if you were to have
a certificate for stability of that set
that I mentioned you could assign the
parameter TS and the gain K through
maybe a certificate like a Lyapunov
function there are many other problems
that fit into the category of hybrid
systems I already mentioned switch
systems I said F sub I F sub Sigma the
same thing Sigma is the switching signal
impulsive system someone gives you this
in post times and every time there is an
impulse the state gets reset to a value
given by the value of the state before
the reset
Harrod ultimate a very powerful way to
model hybrid systems and analyze and
verify hybrid systems we can put this
into our framework there guard
conditions here that will materialize
into the jump set the reset conditions
that will not realize into the jump map
and then you can analyze those systems
using the tools that I owe so to put it
in context of the notions that we need
to introduce one of the notion is as I
mentioned already is asymptotic
stability so asymptotic stability is
something that for a linear system is
exponential stability okay the decay of
convergence to the origin for a linear
system is exponential and you don't
worry about the Purina stability with
attractivity because you get both when
you get one of them I gain values on the
left half-plane of the linear system
will buy you that but for nonlinear
systems you need to separate these
notions because you have nonlinear
systems that have a stability of the
origin but not objectivity attractivity
diverging but not a stability okay all
right so how do we do this we're gonna
start with a set which is known as
center of the origin because of
sample-and-hold already told us we
should not look just at the origin so we
need a set called calligraphed a and I'm
going to say that it's a stable if I
start close to the set then the
solutions a stay close to that set of
so what does that mean that's my set in
the context of my very genetic see on
these let me just say that in most
applications this C and the overlap is a
set of measure zero very thing set but
if you had perturbations into this set
you say well my event is going to occur
here but maybe a little bit more or a
little bit less than here then you can
enlarge the jump set and as soon as you
large it from being very thin
intersection you create a very big
intersection so you might want to start
with a notion that allows for that big
intersection but again this is for
visualization purposes and I'm going to
take a set a that is very generic his
sunset doesn't need to be connected
isn't because it's connected it's not
come back she doesn't need to be convex
and what I would like to know is what
does it mean to be a stable so area that
for every epsilon which in this case
will define essentially a ball around
the set they would have to exist a delta
which most likely will be smaller where
is much smaller than the epsilon such
that if I start within that Delta like I
do there the solution does not leave the
epsilon neighborhood and you need to
show that for every epsilon okay so this
is not easy to check
we need a certificate that doesn't
require the epsilon Sandow thatís so
that's a stability attractive it is a
property that if I start my system at
initial condition the solutions converge
to the set as time gets large but now
think about timing hybrid sense I taught
you that you had T n J so you might
converge in the limit as T goes to
infinity or you might converge in the
limit as K goes to infinity or you might
converge in the limit as both go to
infinity okay it turns out that if you
take the limit as T plus J go to
infinity with T and J in the domain of
the solution everything is good okay
and the notion reduces to what we know
for continuous transistors how do we
guarantee that epsilon Delta and our
activity property again checking for
every epsilon Delta maybe you did it in
some homework problem you probably
suffer as I did
you have a hybrid system let's remove
the input because a stability in the
sense of Lyapunov is for systems with
other inputs and let's create a
closed-loop hybrid system I apply my
feedback already okay
this doesn't happen for MPC per se but
let's say we do how do you guarantee the
stability in that activity property I
need to find a function which is
typically called a Lyapunov function and
i know it has V in this node and that
function is non negative and that
function is only zero in the set you
wanna go okay so it's zero there in a
and everywhere else has to be positive
because I said it's Virtual Console now
what I can do is to guarantee that the
derivative of V is less or equal than
zero which is no more than this inner
product within the grain of V and the
vector field the flow map has on the
points X in C okay if I have this
property and I didn't have any jumps I
will have that the set a is stable for
that system and the beauty said due to
Lyapunov that this doesn't require
epsilon on deltas I'm very important it
doesn't require solutions I don't need
to solve the system solutions okay if I
have you seen equality satisfy which in
some cases if this is quadratic and this
is linear then these are nice
inequalities then you can actually get
stability for the jumps you can think
that now in the context of the screen
time systems every time there is a jump
the new value of V minus the value
before the jump needs to be less or
equal answer in other words if you think
of V as an energy indicator of your
system you should not have your energy
grow because V after the jump will be
less or equal than V before the jump
okay so that's the change of energy make
sense so if that happens then you get a
stability of a in the sense of the
previous life for the hybrid system how
do we get the convergence does anyone
remember how to do that with a Lyapunov
function what do you need to add
let me give a hip all you want now to do
is to guarantee that when you're not in
a these is a strict less than zero so in
other words this quantity can only
vanish when you are in a everywhere else
needs to be negative so basically says
that if your energy is positive and
you're not in a then your derivative of
V needs to be negative to make progress
to be equal to zero
positive energy zero energy in order to
make progress you need to decrease your
energy the variation of energy should be
negative and that's what it is and the
same for the other regime the discrete
regime is that every time that I jump
and I don't make progress with my energy
I had to be in this at a which could be
written as V of G strictly less than B
of X so these are the conditions that
you get and again these are not
requiring any any solution information
or any epsilon Delta there's a caveat
how to find a V right that's a Holy
Grail how to do that and there are ways
to relax these when you don't have these
two things and you have this F C G and D
with some properties and that's what is
called invariance principle
so it's an invariance principle that
allows you to do this I'll just keep
some of those things and I'll see if I
mentioned those conditions later on so
for the sample-and-hold controls that
subletter controller i had earlier now
as I mentioned the set will be 0 plus T
70s across 0 and then here you can see
explicitly the flow set on the jump set
for that system and the flow map and
achai map is in raw form just for
simplicity but that's what we had
earlier something that might be useful
for you is that now you can add
perturbations to this as I said you can
easily model this flows have been a be a
little bit larger with some perturbation
Delta maybe your computer system doesn't
sample every TS maybe samples every TS
plus minus some tolerance which is
almost 100% true and then you can either
into a mode ok and do analysis with any
large jump set and
you can also consider other type of
perturbations like I said minus Delta
plus Delta and then now your events are
going to be all over the place but if in
your design you incorporated that
information and your Lyapunov function
satisfies the stability for that
particular perturbation then you have a
robust design right there okay all right
here's the canonical example of the ball
I don't think I need to spend too much
time but the bonding between the impacts
has flow and that's the flower you see
right there and every time that there is
an impact which is when the height of
the ball is equal to the position of his
piston which are going to assumed to
wishes controllable as by a signal you
and the velocity is negative I have a
restitution and the restitution changes
the velocity and essentially changes the
kinetic energy of the system every time
there is an impact if the resolution
coefficient is a smaller than one and
that's all the type of trajectories that
you get you get again centrally flow and
jump flow and jump and ideally you get
tracking as you see right there the Rev
is the tracking reference and there are
ways to outro buttons but I think I
already kind of mentioned the idea so
essentially what you do is to enlarge
all the objects a little bit with your
robustness put the perturbation that you
want to consider so everything got a
little bit large and a little bit
distorted and now this enlarged or
inflated system now is the system that
you would like to have convergence but
maybe to a neighborhood office said a
maybe just to a neighborhood that will
be enough and the neighborhood will go
to zero converts to a as as the
perturbation goes to zero because there
is some sort of continually going on
there in order to get these properties
which is can be easily written on on a
KL bound but let me just skip that you
need some some properties in the system
as I mentioned already that whenever we
call the hybrid basic conditions nothing
is for free these robust is not for free
you need to have some regularity we need
to have this set C and need to be closed
set of RN okay and we need to have these
maps F and G to be turbulent enough but
let me just give you the case that
I'm going to view of focusing here which
is the case where F and G are single
values all we want is that function f
and that's function G to be continuous
functions and in the examples I
mentioned those functions were linear
linearly affine nicely and continuous so
we want those functions to be continuous
functions of the argument okay
and when that happens then we get the
robustness of the Synthetica stability
of a set that is compact so there's much
more to say about this but now it's time
to tell you that we actually can compute
this thing so we have a toolbox that
runs in matlab and you can pretty much
hand to the system flow set flow map
jump set jam map initial condition some
parameters for simulation which
essentially integration scheme you and I
used in flows and then you will keep you
the solution in the hybrid sense with
tnj of course discretize what about
coming back to multiply to control and I
mention already most of these strategies
what they do is to measure predict
select and apply okay so make sure you
CC predict you need a model select is
very hard how do you solve optimization
problem that's very hard and we are
slowly making progress on that and then
apply the control signal to the plant to
actually create the stability property
but then you repeat this over and over
this is a recurrent algorithm and you
need to do this periodically it depends
on the application that you have so how
do we do how do we do
MPC for hybrid systems with all the
things that you know now
so this is how we do it and again
because we are picking F and G to be
single value we call this hybrid
equations if my system flows I should
attach a cost to that in my assistant
jumps I should attach a cost to that and
if my system gets closed or not to a
terminal set I want to go the Kali
resides set a I need to touch a customer
so the first piece the LC is the stage
cost function for the flows so every
time there are flows so in between TJ
and TJ plus one of an interval I add
Carew cost as long as this TJ plus one
is larger than TJ then there will be
some interval that is non-empty and then
I accrue cost how do i crew cost as a
function of time and I weighed the state
and the input okay hi every time every
time there is a jump J 0 to some number
I accrue cost do two jumps with a stage
cost for the jumps okay these are
functional calligraph j xu is taking
from you a hybrid solution X and higher
input u and it gives you the cost of
that we already talked about that the
question now is discuss is not hard to
put down but the question is how do we
predict where is the prediction gonna
happen is it going to happen in the
t-direction it's gonna happen in the J
direction it should happen in both see
what I mean if it is continuing system
that's just pretty forward in ordinary
time if it is creat I predict forwarding
J again I don't need to predict because
I'm going to formulate a musician
problem that I need to know how to set
up the optimization problem so that's
important to know what is the prediction
horizon okay I'll tell you a little bit
about that and then I like to have this
terminal constraint this is essentially
what I want to go this has said what if
I get there I want you know the price
this is a set where good things happen
from that set I converts to Cali rallies
okay so that's my
terminal constraint said I said I like
to get to after The Horizon happens okay
a prediction horizon so this is the
problem we're gonna solve and I'll tell
you a bit about the prediction horizon
in a minute
give me an initial condition for my
system the problem to solve is minimize
this cost functional subject to the fact
that the precision horizon belongs to
this very generation set and then my
state after the prediction horizon
belongs to the terminal constraint set
okay now this guy here is all the
possible trajectories that I could have
for my system okay because I want to
sweep the entire space that I could
reach from my initial condition with all
possible inputs that he could have and
that is denoted as caligra phase some
each this is an object that we static
whatever kind well it's a set of
solutions to my system think about of a
system as a bag of solutions you pick an
inner condition you're picking one
solution from that bag maybe from an
initial condition there are multiple
elements in that bag non uniqueness no
big deal the bag is bigger okay but that
is a set of all my solutions that I have
okay so I need to sleep over that and
again how to compute this is part of
clear isn't it
we also define a feasible set which is a
set of initial conditions for which
there exists a solution okay and the
value function is the most important
thing is the best cost that you can
attain from a given initial condition
give me an initial condition what's the
best course I could have I'll sweep over
all my solutions over my clothes with my
constraints or my cost function and I
give you the best of orders that's the
value function back to the bouncing ball
example you have a ball that moves up
and down every time to the hits the
ground is there is an impact okay and
imagine that your goal is to stabilize a
particular passing in the movie and an
experiment you want to establish a
particular energy so the ball is
to keep juggling that means a particular
potential plus kinetic energy and
potential is in this case gravity x
times height and kinetic with mass equal
to one is velocity square divided by two
so let's suppose that you wanna do that
and that's what you get that's a nice
linearized system after you start
evolving you get to the right energy and
that's all good if I move a little bit
from the initial condition I'll
eventually make it there and if I move
because I was with much more energy my
controller will take me back ok so that
will be a controller that I'm not tell
you the details but it's an MPC
controller that takes you to the right
energy level and it coped with the jump
now suppose that we want to solve this
with MPC and I said the prediction
horizon is is now this TJ and now I
change a little bit the problem and I
said I want to stabilize just the origin
because the reference particular might
be more difficult than you aren't just
the origin just the origin ok now it
turns out that for that model because
gravity is pulling velocity down from
the origin there are not flows you
cannot flow you can only jump from the
origin
ok so that means that the prediction
horizon if I pick it as a point the fern
identity needs to be served enough loss
then I had to pick T equal to 0 so then
I need to pick something that is known
said otherwise I will not predict if I
pick Sarah Sarah there is no prediction
so I'm going to predict jumps for 1 in
time ok
I predict jumps for any time everything
is good from the origin as soon as I
move the ball from the origin they would
be flow and I cannot predict just jump
because there are not jumps right there
so I get this dilemma that well I can't
predict anymore because from initial
conditions away from the origin I need
to flow so if you take the prediction
horizon set to be a point you run into
this dilemma that 0 0 is your prediction
which is no prediction which is bad
actually what you have to do is to
predict using hybrid structures so this
is a generic hybrid domain of time
Flo jump Flo jump float jump it may be
slightly different job flow jump flow
and so on the way I'm going to predict
this with a box I will need to have a
set which is the prediction horizon set
which is essentially this whole boundary
because I don't know whether the
solution is going to hit that
or that I don't need and not least to
something that is pretty simple then we
just put here for hybrid system you
should predict using a set for instance
the maximum between T and J is for
either a predict four seconds of flow or
for jumps no matter which one it is I'm
going to predict something right and
once I think about that might be my
prediction horizon which is that box
that I mentioned just now
then I might apply my control for two in
the sense of Max T and J for two seconds
of flow or two jumps and as soon as I do
that I recompute see this is not going
to be periodic anymore because once you
jump this J jumps by one and you might
have two jumps and there is no
periodicity right now okay so that's the
beauty of the prediction horizon said
even though you need to depart from the
standard continuous time MPC or discrete
time in PC for the prediction now you
can think of and this is with our
toolbox you can think of okay
flow jump flow jump now I apply so I
predict for four seconds I apply for two
seconds after those two seconds I
predict for four I apply for two if you
were me and you keep getting closer and
closer to the energy level all right it
turns out that we get for this ball
close to an energy level in that bit
time in one jump very nice if you are
constraint then you can relax that I
will skip the sample and hold that let
me just say that you can now solve
something a whole control quick
characterization of the time in between
events and then the sample behavior
using
a hybrid scheme how does this work what
is behind the hood in the next less than
five minutes that I have how do we make
this all this work we need some
assumptions first we need the stage cost
for the flows and for the jumps to be
lower bounded by a quantity that only
vanishes when you're in the set you want
to go okay that's a standard property of
a stage cost you're familiar with X
transpose QX that is satisfy for the
origin okay we want to have the terminal
constraint which is that in this case
the view of the Lyapunov function to be
sandwiched by a standard K infinity
bounds from below and from below so that
when we are with zero terminal cost we
know that we are in the set we want to
go just a nice indicator okay so these
are well known and mirror those for
continuous time and discrete time we
also want they said we want to stabilize
to be somewhat somewhat reasonable so we
want that set to be contained to some
extent in my terminal constraint set
okay my temper constraint set is what
I'm solving for in time so they said
that I want to go should better be
somewhere there and that's also standard
it's a relative interior property and
then I like this slightly technical
assumption that I have some growth
control on my flows and that's also
satisfy if F is continuous which is
typically the case and the set a is
compact with a flow that is first set
there is another structure so with that
what we can do is now focus our
attention on the constraint set on the
constraint set which I said is where my
optimization and prediction is taking me
I better have something that makes
things work to take me to the set
calligraphic from there and that's what
is called a control Lyapunov function so
not terminal constraint set we would
like to have and this is probably
familiar to you now from the previous
lies about eccentric stability for
hybrid systems using Lyapunov functions
that represented I would like to have a
pair of feedbacks
play very nicely with the terminal
constraint V and with the stage costs
okay and this is again this is a
standard in MPC literature for
continuous time system and standard for
the MPC digital or discrete-time systems
that follow the CLF approach controller
burn of function and under those
conditions then we have all the
ingredients what happens is that we have
forward invariance of the terminal
constraint set and with that we can now
actually execute and guarantee that
we're going to converge now our comments
should be made here I don't need to know
this I know I need to know that there
exists because my optimizer will find it
for me so all I know is that it exists
so there are some conditions in the
literature on how to guarantee that
there exists a controller Pro function
and some conditions using
CLF for also for very functions and for
forwarding bias I won't have time for
that but those are available so with all
that we can have a stability and
attractivity of a set we can prove
visibility we can prove local continuity
of the value function which is the key
quantity that you would like to have and
also positive definiteness and these are
essentially the building blocks that
lead to the following very important
thing is that the value function now a
long time is a strictly decreasing and
that is given by the boundary C right
there and it will converge to the
optimal value as time evolves and and
this is essentially the result that we
can recover Synthetica stability of a
set using that that construction I will
not have a lot of time to give you a
script accession approach but you will
see the recording and I'll be happy to
provide the slides but we can discretize
all these objects you actually going to
present this at the CDC we have a paper
during the regular track so if you are
attending feel free to go there we can
discretize the flows we can discretize
the gems we can discretize the flow cell
we can discretize the jump set and then
compute the question is how do we solve
optimization problem and that's where we
are in need of need of help the problem
now becomes a discretization so the
minimization is over the discrete I said
that's the
that right there and we get essentially
an optimization program that is is
discretized in time so now it's all
discrete time the flows are right there
and the jumps are right there this
variable X tilde is my new state in the
discretization stage and I also keep
track of time that I use the input for
the flow or the input for the jumps
that's the problem that we saw we have
an opt I toolbox implementation which is
off the shelf open source at least we
know what's going on right there and
things that are thoroughly useful they
the idea will be to be able to find
problems and a class of hybrid systems
where we can put it into this framework
we haven't done it but if F G are linear
and C and they are polytopes they should
work right away and if anyone is
interested in working on that start open
what is this enabling us it's never
enough to do trajectory tracking with
optimality this is a very rough run but
then you can think of there it goes
booster so this is tracking with with
MPC of a biped compass model it's a
little bit slower and slower you can
again tune to the cost function how you
do tracking for my pets
movie business
all right this is my newer inverter with
prediction every time that now I'm
tracking every time that I hit the
boundary of this particular ball that I
wanna generate I predict my motions of
my circuit and I pick the best to
actually minimize switching time we get
a huge reduction on switching time with
this inverter by using prediction by
essentially picking the configuration of
the transistors that will give me
essentially the most time to the next
switch any one video games so we have a
computational media group very strong
you can do motion planning using
predictive control predictive hybrid
where now you want to send slappy
without hitting any obstacle in future
and then compute that and then find the
right particular it's very tight up
there but it makes it and this is
something that we done with my now
student Jeremy that I think it was here
somewhere
now it's a must have seen here working
on Huayra predictive for reactive
evasion where now you solve this
optimization problem with set-based
techniques to actually try to avoid
these threads that come at you in these
to the interest of time I'll show you
one or two of these and then I'll show
you the the predictive part right there
okay so right here is where it gets
quite interesting now the throw is
actually going to hit the vehicle moves
away why does it move away because the
computers to the algorithm which is MPC
that it was an intersection between the
safety area of the vehicle and the
prediction of this projectile which is
another mathematical model that we use
and under that it reacts okay what we
are showing here is that this
optimization promise can be written down
proven analytically and also implemented
in practice and this is one of those
examples actually represented at the
case
this past summer and Jeremy did that as
part of actually the finalists for the
best prepare worse that was very
exciting so there are many other
questions right here
hybrid invariance how do you maximum
principle very interesting necessary
conditions for optimality there are some
out there how do we relax the structure
of the prediction horizon
how do we the tracking and how do we
guarantee robustness lot of things thank
you for attention thank you absolutely
if you put symmetry and you put the
structure of the system then you're
under control then you might have a good
hint to what will be a goodly Epona
function so for instance the trivial one
which is the bouncing ball which again
now I'm probably like stably bouncing
balls bouncing balls capture walking
robots simplifications capture
mechanical systems with impact
simplifications then in that case taking
kinetic plus potential is a very good
quantity it turns out that kinetic plus
potential is not a strictly decreasing
during flows it's only decreasing at the
impact so now you need to use this
relaxation that I mentioned the
invariance principle if you have only
decreases in flows and not decreases in
jams or the other way around like in
this a mechanical system can you still
say something about convergence the
answer is yes the answer is C sauce for
MPC for MPC weak and the only stage cost
flow or only a stage jump cost and again
the only thing I see from the structure
of a system I can do is to get inform
and educate about what would be these
functions for this particular class of
systems
[Applause]